[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul AKA your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and this video
we're breaking down Marvel Spider-Man
[Music]
2 Marvel Spider-Man 2 really makes you
feel like Spider-Man and I can't wait to
talk about everything going on with it
we've been going through the PS5 game at
break next speed like Gwen Stacy cuz
this thing's been living in our head Ren
free like Mr dickov's Number One tenant
give me rent throughout this video we'll
be talking about the major plot points
in the game and also discussing the
ending and where it could be going heavy
spoilers ahead so if you don't want
anything ruined then don't click in an
explain video smash the Thumbs Up Button
hit the Subscribe do all that stuff and
join the spoiler Society without the way
a huge thank you for clicking this now
let's get into Marvel's Spider-Man 2
what are you
writing the Final
Chapter now the game begins with Peter
and Miles as the Protectors of New York
with them both having to deal with how
their heroics affect their lives Peter's
managed to land a job teaching at
Brooklyn's Visions Academy and in his
class as miles who's applying for
colleges he's joined by his love
interest Haley from the spin-off games
and it seems like they're all finally
making their way in the world now though
life seems sweet it doesn't last long
and we Kickstart the action with sanman
attacking the city it's like Anakin
Skywalker's worst nightmare and both
Peter and Miles have to go out and
handle it this leads to the ladder
getting fired from his job and to make
matters worse MJ could be too the pair
are together again with Peter living in
Maine Ben's house and though they don't
have much they at least have each other
however things aren't come for too long
and we see that 6 months ago Craven the
hunter was looking for new challenges
getting to bored because everything's
too easy he's decided to head out to New
York's Urban Jungle he knows the city's
filled with both villains and heroes
alike and it's going to make for a major
Battleground now this is sort of based
on the Ultimate Spider-Man run and which
really wanted to prove himself as the
ultimate Hunter hitting up the city he
becomes a major antagonist which is made
even worse by some of the other villains
now as we learn throughout the story
Craven's actually dying of cancer and
his wishes to guard and battle against
someone who's strong enough to best him
he's not the only one who's Gravely ill
either and early on we see what's been
going on with Harry who was teased out
in several of the bonus features from
the other games we catch kir con as has
been working on him and as I'm sure you
can guess he ends up becoming the lizard
venom has also been helping heal Harry
too which is of course something that
the other games alluded to Benin of
killing Craven and basically becoming a
major threat in the city that all ramps
up towards the game's
ending
now for this part of the video I'm going
to talk about a secret scene that you
only get upon completing the spider Bo
Quest once done that opens up and across
the spiderverse bonus scene in which we
get some ties in with the film Universe
now in case you don't know the film
originally had a deleted scene that
showed a bar with a Bart tender known as
Delila this was known as the bar with no
name which too pops up during the game
opening a portal up she says she'll take
the Bots back and one point even
mentions Miguel this is of course
Spider-Man 2099 who was one of the big
antagonists during that film and
absolutely love it if the game tied in
with that and as we know the Spider-Man
from this universe also featured in the
film potentially in Spider-Man 3 we
might even get some crossover characters
with them coming to this world to help
sort it out also the spiderbots in
general may be a reference to Superior
Spider-Man with him inventing the
technology when he was in the role now
we will talk about some other SP SP is
popping up later but that bonus scene
could tease what's going on I'll save
that for later though and he watches
Peter wrestles with the Symbio taking
control over him as always this makes
him turn to the dark side but it's a
connection to Harry that really shakes
things up in the PlayStation Universe
we've not had a Green Goblin and
shifting Venom to Harry ramps up the
stakes mj2 gets taken by it as well and
at one point she becomes the villain
scream now this is because Venom's been
giving simotes to people in the city and
it leads to a big boss battle with her
I'm pretty sure it never attached to MJ
in the comics but the shifting to a more
personal setting really hits home KN in
the end the heroes destroy the meteorite
that brought Venom in which takes out
the Symbio but in doing this ATMs Harry
Harry's death was also a big thing in
the comics too with him becoming the
Green Goblin and one of spidey's big
villains now miles was actually given
new powers by mon Lee and this allows
him to revive the character which is
when he sent to hospital his father
Norman blames the heroes for his poor
health and we sees he's taken home and
put in a hospital bed there are traces
of brain activity but he's basically a
vegetable and there's very little chance
the character is going to come back but
he probably will spoiler alert now
although Peter and MJ have been looking
out for him his dad's still desperate to
heal his son and he's never going to
accept that his child is going to die
wearing a green jacket this kind of
shows what direction he's going to be
going in and Norman grabs Harry's Kane
and starts using it to smash things like
they the like button this leads to Peter
and MJ clearing out and then Norman
makes a call and says get the GC room
ready this clearly highlights what's
going to be happening in the next game
and this will likely lead to the debut
of the Green Goblin this will finally
bring spidey's big bad into the
Limelight and I'm surprised they managed
to hold them up for that long when you
think about it we're going to be four
games deep at that point and yeah
leaving the Green Goblin until then hats
off to them now in case you don't know
the GC room gave Norman improved
strength but it's also something that
caused him to go insane this couple with
his anger and grief is going to make for
a highly unstable villain and he's now
ready to do whatever he can to get
revenge on the spidies now it's possible
that the G serum could also be used to
heal Harry too as in the comics like we
said he was also the Green Goblin
personally though I'd like to see Norman
become the big bad as so far he's only
remained a villain on the political
level so yeah I think he'll be the one
that takes the serum and this will give
him the powers to fight the spiders to
make matters worse he's also started
reaching out to other villains which
then takes the sin of that post-credit
scene that has Norman visiting o at the
raft who's been in prison since the very
first game he asks if Otto will reveal
the Spider-Man identities but o refuses
and thinks it's good Harry and Norman a
suffering this is kind of like that post
credit scene for Spider-Man homecoming
when vulture refused to do the same
thing lucky for him or well unlucky for
him he's now out there in the morus
universe however things aren over with
Arc and we discover is he's writing
something known as is the Final Chapter
I'm guessing that the next one's going
to be the final one in the trilogy and
it could potentially Link in with a
possible comic book shout outs to IGN
for breaking down both comic books that
carry the name final chapter and I'm
guessing that they're going to take
inspiration from both the first is The
Amazing Spider-Man 33 from 1965 which
I'm sure you'll instantly recognize the
cover of it's absolutely iconic and in
this story we see Peter getting trapped
into some Rubble whole thing is about
him basically persevering in in order to
get himself out which is something that
we may see happening in the next game
the happy moments like this lay
throughout the game series so far but
I'm excited to see if that pops up down
the line now the second Final Chapter
centered around the Green Goblin who
initiates a ritual known as the
Gathering of the five this itself as
fire relics which give five people
certain outcomes there's power knowledge
immortality insanity and death which
each of the five in it basically are
gambling their Fates on Norman believed
that he got power when in the end we
learn that he wants more God Insanity
knowledge also seemed like it was
Madness and there were some nice twists
that happened along the way now they may
call it Spider-Man 3 the Final Chapter
or they could head into another
Direction now personally I believe we'll
get another miles game in between that
sort of acts as an expansion like what
came before why do you say that Paul
well let's look at what happens at the
end and kind of discuss where things
could be going so we close out with MJ
starting up a podcast and hey stay off
me Patcher also me and Greg from real
rejects run a podcast called across the
spoe where we talk movie news give
reviews and just life in general it's on
Spotify Amazon and YouTube too so please
keep an eye out for that and yeah I hope
you guys are enjoying it anyway we end
with Miles and Haley talking about how
he's trying to live up to his father
what we learn is that Peter's taking
some time out to be Peter and miles is
now going to be the one looking after
the city both him and MJ going full
force with the Emily May Foundation
which is named after Aunt May and
Harry's mother Emily Harry initially
joined his co-founder and this was set
up to heal a world make it a better
place for for you and for me and the
entire human race There Are People Dying
now Peter we'll just focus on that while
miles says he can hold down the city I
think Peter will return and though
there's people speculating that it's
Spider-Man no more I personally think
that it'll be back in the red white and
blue anyway miles might be getting
someone under his wing and becoming a
mentor like
early in the game his mother says she's
been deading someone and we find out who
this is in the final scene this is
Albert he's been desperate to finally
meet Rio's son and he brings along his
own kid who's called Cindy uh hi nice to
meet
you oh and uh this is my daughter
[Music]
Cindy now that instant cut to Black
obviously she's important and in case
you don't know this is Cindy Moon Cindy
moon is none other than silk a major
hero from the comics that I feel is
going to go into miles's Wing now Sydney
was bit by an radiated spider and as we
all know instant spider powers Cindy has
all the abilities that come with it
along with Organic web shooters and a
silk scent I'm not kidding that's it's
called a silk scent now I can see a
spin-off a spin-off cuz spider spin web
say um but I can see a spin-off game
with with miles now being a mentor to
his new friend I think this will then
lead into the main game and set up Ox
release along with the arrival of the
Green Goblin this will then all go down
in the third main game with Peter
returning due to how the threat
escalates there's also other villains
set up in the game too with a chaman and
Carnage both probably becoming bigger
players all in all there's lots of
things coming down the line and I can't
wait to see what happens in the next
game this is really becoming one of the
best comic book game series of all time
and it's an incredible story to get to
through that I hope you've enjoyed us
talking about if you have any other
theories then please drop them below and
let me know where you think things will
be going next time also huge shout out
to the channel gameclips where we got
the footage from I left that watermark
on the video cuz I didn't want to just
erase it but thanks to them for
collecting all that footage now please
drop a like on the video and if you want
to support the channel as a member of
the spoiler Society then please click
the join button you'll get early access
to videos every week and it goes such a
long way to helping videos like this get
made you want to get some heavy while as
merch we've also got a t-shirt line
located below the video that will let
you pick up all kinds of tops like our
Theory time one house of dragon stuff
Marvel teason a lot more we drop new
designs on there all the time too so
definitely keep an eye out and huge
thank you for supporting it if you want
something else to watch we've got some
lowkey videos on screen right now so
definitely check them out if you're
wondering what's happening in the show
huge thank you to everyone who's been
supporting the channel over the last
couple of months it really means a lot
and yeah thank you so much without the
way I'm Paul You' been the best and I'll
see you next time take care peace